si dans certaines régions de france les
vendanges ont déjà commencé ce n'est pas
encore le cas en bourgogne et c'est
peut-être l'occasion de découvrir
quelques-uns des plus beaux vignobles
comme le prestigieux gevrey chambertin
et cela de manière assez originale
alain douves skis jean-françois chevet
nous sommes donc en chambertin claude
bez le grand cru le plus fameux de
gevrey chambertin
le ton est donné la balade se fera dans
un cadre prestigieux plus que le simple
promenade dans les vignes
il s'agit de découverte du terroir des
véritables leçons choses sur le vignoble
et le vent
ces balades ont lieu en été tous les
jours sauf le lundi le matin et
l'après-midi à couper les raisins vert
en coupe
les raisins oui cette femme a au nom
c'est pas demain dans lesquelles s parts
de gevrey chambertin et du clos de
vougeot des noms qui éblouissent quand
même des noms magnifique un des noms de
villages et lonza qu'on connaît bien
puis là dans cette cause parce que vous
milieu se rend compte de ce que ça et
puis n'a comme ça de voir un petit peu
comment ça se travaille
ce sont les professionnels qui
commentait promenade ils doivent trouver
les mots justes pour des visiteurs
parfois peu informés ce sont des
touristes toutes les origines qui
viennent soit pour promener les enfants
et leur montrer des choses nouvelles et
surtout les shows ou bien des gens
passionnés par la vigne qui veulent
venir découvrir d'une manière un petit
peu différente parce que c'est que la
vigne en bourgogne
qu'est-ce qu'ils aient de plus à ce
qu'il est un navet le plus c'est l'âge
de la vigne on nous fait la durée de vie
de la vigne est comparable à celle de
l'homme l'est à pleine maturité entre 20
et 40 ans et à partir de 40 ans les
commence à vieillir et c'est à dire
qu'elle va produire beaucoup moins et
mais par contre les réserves hall 2
qu'elle est bien meilleure la ville peut
vivre jusqu'à 80 la balade d'une heure
coûte 100 francs par personne
dégustation comprise bien sûr
magnifique bon enfin oui ça encore dix
ans il sera parfait un salaire bien